moi j'arrête pas de danser bonne idée
il est ainsi spence insupportable on
veut le tout savoir c'est vrai c'est
vrai merci merci pour ce que tu as dit
antoine bonsoir à tous je me souviens
d'avoir mangé une soupe avec jean carmet
dans une cuisine formica des années 50
petit ou banale carottes poireaux pommes
de terre préparé par le chef
accessoiriste sauf qu'autour de la table
il y avait catherine deneuve
richard bohringer et bernard giraud bien
c'est exactement le même texte que celui
que nous à lui isabelle carré au début
de la cérémonie
pas du tout
non qu'est ce c'est pas ça continuez et
le sentiment un peu inconfortable de
chercher l'erreur est d'être soi-même
l'erreur c'est inconfortable mais c'est
assez exaltant
d'autant plus qu'il s'agit d'une scène
d'engueulades oui donc en fait vous
allez tout copié au mot près quoi
oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai copié
j'ai copié mais attends je veux te dire
pourquoi j'ai compris antoine parce
qu'en fait comme je c'est là que c'est
très stressant que pour les filtres que
la normale le temps le temps paraît plus
long parce qu on stresse pas rebooster
ses kits nous allons vite savoir c'est
long donc je me suis dit je vais faire
court voyez donc je vais rien faire
oui le but à l'heure tout ce que
j'entends c'est hyper bien se préparer
je n'avais pas envie de passer pour un
fumiste
quand je me suis dit je vais copier mais
je vais couper les malins car et je
copie sur isabelle carré parce que déjà
je n'aime bien et sont aix il était beau
et comme elle c'est l'actrice qu'elle a
eu le césar de la meilleure actrice
ça fait truc en plus c'était au début
c'est pas redondant enfin je me dis là
c'est bien choisie comme tout juste un
mois donc du coup c'est pour ça mais là
ce jour sinon j'aurais préparé si on
m'avait dit avant parce que personne n'a
bien qu omar juste l'idée c'est de faire
cours justement à madaba le savons un
passionnant